olá tudo bem
é tanta gente rolar mãe foi gente
disseram olha faltou uma pessoa não tem
portas lá pra cima do palco entreter os
clientes
tudo bem e agora o que eu vou falar
pensar e dizer coisas bonitas fica
sempre banho então experimentar esta
esta tarde que vivemos pois translúcidas
e palestras espetáculos e queria pedir
uma salva de palmas para toda a equipa
do telex para baixo
parecia com a salvação que deram aos
senhores e senhoras estiveram aqui
cantar interrompa essa história de
aprendi muito
sai daqui com conhecimento mais alargado
e positivista e mais uma vez obrigado
aos pontos trânsito pelo empenho e
partilha
cabe a mim é tarefa doença rara e
sintetizar o que se passou esta tarde
então vamos lá aos factos
o cláudio tomaz próprio cláudio
o cláudio vamos falar sobre as pequenas
coisas
afinal também importam e daí não ter
falado na cadeira de ctct coleciona e
tanto entusiasmo aos alunos porque não
se recorda ctct significa cadeira
teórica confusa e tramava falamos também
da sua experiência na única entrevista
trabalho tempo e o facto de lhe terem
perguntado como era a sua relação com as
- cláudio eu até percebo se tivermos em
conta esta foto lá pode querer berdych
ivo é glória lei pn +6 temos a
interromper mas eu tenho uma solução
criança explica o ator
qualquer dia vamos lá 1 a conseg canelas
perceber como é que funcionam
e ele já sem qualquer coisinha
só tem um problema já vem em mau estado
mas são simpáticas atenção e agora devem
estar curiosos como eu fiquei como excel
cláudio depois descobrir o que são as
mulheres
como é que eu ficará então ficará assim
com menos em deus mas fui por outro lado
temos a dolina thomas farley natais
a lei está
adelina muito à frente da sua geração
não to org o primeiro foi da
apresentação do boi bomba muito à frente
já vez pequenina que usavam mirim e qual
era o nome com que ela fazia lobby né
que do shea te quero
segundo ela para fazer amizades só por
vezes apareciam pessoas assim vidas
pessoais a para cada um sabe de si
os alunos da professora adelina adora
uma forma de alargar aulas e uma aluna
disse mesmo das coisas mais bonitas que
ela podia ter ouvido ontem for time de
ouvir a história enquanto a valores a
bonita inspiradores e eu que já fui
aluno da professora dorina confirma e
lembro perfeitamente quando os pratos e
não vai ouvir a história
e gravação era mais ou menos o seguinte
metro gente frango ao prato metros genus
foi o prato metros - foi ampla
um segmento de tecnologias a visita
agora a palmas 40 daniel estava ganha a
vida vai me falar sobre o enem
e pra quem não sabe ler nem pode ser
chamado também de ensino via internet e
é isso que é pra mim o ar nem postar uma
foto no estilo a uma foto e pistola no
instagram e com esta fotografia eu
descobri um mundo o mundo maravilhoso
dos pés não tenham fé texto nada disso
mas conheci muitas pessoas interessantes
com esta fotografia por exemplo aquela
senhora já disseram que têm os pés links
calça 38 em maio tem dois joanetes e
unhas aparadas prefeita
temos trocado e contatos conhecer melhor
uma interessa como começa o confronto
começa a entrar sem motivação como
fazemos isso a rita falou aqui e muito
vai na sua apresentação a uma coisa
melhor para motivar os alunos do colocar
dois alunos do sexo oposto a trabalharem
juntos a partilharem o chefe da
universidade a tornarem universidade no
lugar
ao contrário do que muitas pessoas
pensam que a universidade é o não lugar
e evitar frio isso aqui e muito bem
porquê porque já miguel relvas tem a
universidade como num lugar
ae
é aqui mesmo as tecnologias reforçadas
ainda brincava com isso na volta então
ainda novas oito universidades escolas
deixem de ser um lugar os jogos mas faz
a é um fartote isso ataque os olhos de
uma professora para dar lugar a jorge
caiu então pode ser que os jogos vai nos
mostrar como pode ser divertida a
matemática com importantes para as
nossas vidas e eu eu concordo porque eu
pude logo aqui com o pensamento de
matemáticos não vai só a companhia não é
matemática é difícil mas pra vocês
apenas opina se como diz jorge jesus mas
também vai falar só agora a matemática é
igual é circo o circo é igual à natal eo
metal é igual é sempre que o homem
quiser então por uma associação qualquer
comutativo não saiba nunca fui romã é
matemática é sempre que o homem quiser
e eu tenho pra mim que se a matemática
for sempre que os alunos que quiserem
tevez já que as aulas vão estar vazias e
o que é quase do mesmo nível que a
matemática é a história dessa coisa que
entusiasma matemática história é assim
era daquelas disciplinas que eu e aí fui
por sinal a entrada em casa e o henrique
a palmas vai ter o henrique eo elenco
vai nos falado como aprender a história
gostando tornando interessante naquela
altura não havia computadores
eu disse aqui uma coisa muito
interessante com sustentou curiosidade
fui treinado para ser cientista
só depois é que começou a dar aulas que
o país não ia pensar na cadeira é como é
que o indivíduo é treinador de 63 em 30
junho nos quais concluíram que a outra
leva eu erre um frasco é 2 gotas lá se
vai a porta a faixa agitada chuvas
iphone depois no final a não conseguir
nem vou ensinar a história
um dia o que faltava esta tarde o peixe
sempre feitas 13 no topo do ou falar
filosofia para crianças
palmas para joana
desde já quero agradecer a joana por ter
entregue o público mais de controle pois
aquela preguiça dela só com esta coisa
dos micros maquiagens e não tive tempo
peço só dois ou três segundos prémios
prevista também para ficar assim ao
nosso nível
neste momento acaba de ganhar uma aposta
cristina não acreditava que eu iria
espreguiçar em palco que ela não devia
ter foi porque segundo paula bobone é
falta de educação
eu tenho a xuxa chega perguntas
eu tenho uma pergunta da platéia porque
filosofia para crianças
as luzes do santa é bom para a opção a
que ajuda ao desenvolvimento do negócio
opção b para lhes ensinar a dizer assim
não senão durante toda a resposta forma
par sexual bem como um bom filósofo
opção c
essa pergunta não faz sentido e o bruno
é maluco qual é que querem escolher se a
resposta certa palmas pra vocês
depois da filosofia
nada melhor que alguém da psicologia
entre uma coisa acaba e eu tenho um só
pelo meio pra mim e josé paulo aposenta
mas a minha esquecer o epa josé vai me
falar sobre a diferenciação do trabalho
com as crianças mas isso já não é novo
já no meu tempo na escola havia
diferenciação a professora perdão a
professora fazia diferenciação com os
meus colegas
havia aqueles que queriam fazer e os que
não queriam fazer depois a nivel também
das competências aviões que seguiam e os
que não sabiam
na altura a professora até dava nomes
para ser mais fácil para os gols seus
perto depois falamos em outra coisa
interessante que é a autonomia
no meu caso são 10 horas em stand by e
quatro de confecção
quanto a valores e cristina é o cachê
que tínhamos acordado mas do valor do
valor é o conune veio aqui fazer e está
a tentar mudar a mentalidade das pessoas
nomeadamente dos jovens com o chefe de
peso na zona lá é tão fofinho que é
mesmo alterar este dá vontade de querer
mandar pra cima como se fosse um colchão
d'água
a iata fofinho pa
frank tem direito mas ao menos posso dar
uma uma sugestão pós é fácil é bacana
ver quem é o que eu sugiro sugiro que os
jovens com o chefe do peso como mais
carnes brancas
sei lá por exemplo coelho não engorda
faz primeiro peso e engraçado
o nono trouxemos aqui um carrinho de
compras
eu queria salientar que tudo o que é o
teu lá dentro conseguiu comprar com os
20 euros do aumento do salário mínimo é
pá espetáculo ano e agora cria a vossa
colaboração luzes é isso é quando então
apenas a epa esquece mas lucas vantagem
voltou a brincar pode ficar assim como é
óbvio depois de tanta carne branca
imaginam como é que ficam os meninos não
é com menos cinco quilos mais felizes
agora sim levantar as luzes e vamos
então um exercício
estes dois jovens o mais fino que o
outro tenha inventar seu braço direito
e peço eu vou fazer uma pergunta
e vocês com voz do braço direito vão
apontar para o que acham que é certo
um é o google o outro é o quique qual é
que o google a da bomba
isso tem uma razão de ser
eu não vou explicar se não manuel
mantinha vai não vai tentar fazer o
manel paulão léo vai nos falar da
acústica na sala de aula o tempo já
acabou não faz mal
o hotel vai falar com o esquema sala de
aula a importância que tem a forma como
a mensagem chega aos alunos e o que eu
proponho eu proponho uma acústica em
ponto é uma mensagem que não se percebem
melhor ficar atento mais receptivos e um
anel como é o homem da vida artística e
tava entravam em pó nomeadamente nas
teclas toda a gente sabe que o ibope
teclas é a razão e ela pra lá deus que a
cut a ousadia de perguntado como nelson
quer partilhar o palco comigo para o
seguinte reconhecimento ao papel
bom pra já não pode ficar assim
então é assim aquela fotografia vai
ficar mais ou menos como se tivessem
surf com as teclas cessar sentar lá e
não tem que ser dentro do circo é um
problema
pronto tá ótimo morel talley com as
teclas
então o que vai acontecer aqui vamos
terminar e não aceitavam essa não voltem
a trabalhar os glúteos agora aqui vamos
terminar isto com um momento musical só
de salvaguarda lá que a minha voz está
para o canto como castel branco está
para ser a mãe
por isso eu vou ter aqui uma acaba da
letra é um caminho improvisado está
afinado está em causa é um pronto então
tenho que apresentam ao lado está o
exército está em ippon toque de gênio
então vá em 321 o manel o nosso artista
vai o alternext fazer de tecnologista
chegou ao palco falou em 10 iguais toda
a gente que inclui os brasilienses tons
papai espera lá então que eu vou
explicar a opção é se vai ser antes de
começado a cortar e parece que falar
pois o cão estava sempre a dar chegou
chegou a criança sempre a chorar ea
cristina diz faster do mês puxado viu
titanic trouxe um iceberg 1 2 milhão
isso é sobre a questão rapidamente pediu
desculpas a eles diz confusão
estamos acabados espero que tenham
gostado pois este ex pra mim vai ficar
guardado estar aqui convosco foi um
prazer foi mesmo tão bom jamais vou
esquecer